du jamais vu depuis les obsèques de
winston churchill le cortège funéraire
de la reine-mère traverse le centre de
londres
entouré par la famille royale et plus de
200000 britannique
l'opération coup de poing des douaniers
qui ont bloqué un eurostar ce matin
différentes actions pour faire pression
sur les pouvoirs publics ils réclament
l'ouverture de négociations sur leur
salaire à bethléem l'évacuation de
ressortissants français et italiens
notamment entré volontairement la
semaine dernière comme boucliers humains
en route vers le grand chelem c'est bien
l'histoire des tricolores qui
affronteront demain à l'irlande au stade
de france
alors côté bien sûr leur entraîneur
bernard laporte
encensé par ses joueurs qui apprécient
ces méthodes madame monsieur bonsoir la
famille royale britannique rend hommage
à la reine mère dont le cercueil orné de
sa propre couronne a traversé le centre
historique de londres
un cortège funéraire suivi par le duc
d'edimbourg les petits enfants et les
arrières petits-fils de queen même aux
côtés des princes william et harry
des milliers d'anglais pour saluer une
dernière fois la reine-mère au total
quelques 200000 britanniques qui se sont
recueillis avant les obsèques nationales
qui se dérouleront mardi prochain
laurent boussier dominique marault tél
un hommage digne d'une reine comme
savent si bien le faire les britanniques
il est 11h30 à londres ce matin quand le
cercle de la reine-mère posé sur un
affûtent d'artillerie tiré par six
chevaux quitte le palais saint-james 30
minutes de procession jusqu'à
westminster et pour l'accompagner au son
des canons qui retentissent toutes les
minutes
3000 militaires anglais écossais gallois
mais aussi canadiens australiens sud
africain sur le cercueil sa couronne
qu'elle n'apportait qu'une fois et un
bouquet de fleurs blanches de sa fille
la reine elizabeth au premier rang de la
procession le prince charles que l'on
verra pleurer pour la première fois en
public puis william et harry qui
accompagne le cercueil de leur arrière
grand mère avec la même dignité qu'il y
a cinq ans quand il suivait celui de
leur mère la princesse diana dans la
foule très importante qui depuis l'aube
se pressent sur le trajet beaucoup de
cheveux blancs mais aussi beaucoup de
jeunes et de familles
l'ambiance n'est pas triste plutôt
recueillies on est loin de l'émotion
suscitée par le décès de la princesse de
galles affaire de génération
certainement je n'ai jamais vu la
famille royale de cyprès pour moi c'est
à la fois triste intéressant cela va
être la fin d'une époque
je pense que la monarchie britannique va
certainement changer
un peu avant midi le cercueil a été
déposé dans le grand rôle de westminster
où l'attendait la reine et tout le
gouvernement du royaume uni depuis le
début de cet après midi des milliers de
londoniens de britanniques ou de simples
touristes sont venus rendre un dernier
hommage à la reine mère quatre heures
d'attentes minimum pour pénétrer dans le
hall de westminster et il va en être de
même pendant trois jours jusqu'à mardi
prochain 9 avril date des funérailles à
proprement parler de l'autre côté de la
manche à la sortie du tunnel coup
d'éclat des douaniers qui ont bloqué un
eurostar ils multiplient leurs
opérations de protestation
un mouvement qui ne fait que s'amplifier
mettre la pression sur le gouvernement
pour qu'il se décide à ouvrir des
négociations salariales c'est une crise
pire sur les voies enchaînement sur les
rails les douaniers souhaitait se faire
en temps ce matin à calais vite délogés
par les crs ils ont tout de même retardé
pendant plus d'une heure le passage d'un
eurostar ambiance plus tendue sur le
port de calais où les grévistes ont
tenté d'empêcher l'embarquement de
camions sur les ferries est pas la force
qui fera la réponse à nos revendications
légitimes préfet à votre manif engagé le
15 mars leur mouvement est selon eux peu
entendus par leur ministre laurent
fabius
on n'est absolument pas écouté il veut
même pas nous recevoir donc c'est un
véritable mépris nous sommes les oubliés
du ministère de de monsieur fabius à
calais comme à bordeaux ils voulaient
mettre en avant leur rôle de
surveillance car sur 19500 douaniers
9000 effectué des contrôles et participe
au plan vigipirate
alors aujourd'hui il réclame la même
prime de risque que leurs collègues
gendarmes ou policiers et une meilleure
prise en compte de leurs points retraite
les douaniers qui sont aujourd'hui sur
des contrôles routiers sont tous les
jours tous les jours forcé par des
passages en force par des gens qui ne
s'arrête plus aux injonctions
mais cet après midi plus personne ne
passait au terminal de ferry de saint
malo ou ici au poste frontière
franco-espagnole du perthus une journée
d'action avec un premier résultat
une délégation sera reçue la semaine
prochaine au ministère de l'économie
josé bové ira-t-il en prison il
rencontrait aujourd'hui le juge
d'application des peines qui lui propose
d'aménager sa condamnation pour le
saccage du mcdonald's en 1999
mais le leader de la confédération
paysanne se déclare pour le tout au rien
liberté ou incarcération réponse très
certainement après les élections a
toulouse la catastrophe de l'usiné azf
continue d'avoir des répercussions sur
la situation de certains salariés qui ne
sont toujours pas recensés comme
personnel sinistrés ils seraient des
centaines à vivre aujourd'hui dans la
précarité au chômage plus de six mois
après l'explosion
isabelle de lyon olivier coup mon dieu
avant à qui la travaillent et qui fera
c'est là mon bureau mon dieu quand elle
y revient elle fallu beaucoup de vagues
l'explosion qui a tout dévasté lui a
coûté son emploi
une dizaine de personnes vrai dans ce
foyer après la catastrophe il ya eu le
chômage technique
puis on leur a dit merci à celui de
partout notre travail a été détruit par
l'explosion
on nous laisse ainsi et on se retrouve
du jour au lendemain sans plus rien de
nombreux toulousains licenciés pour
motif économique subissent les effets
indirects de l'explosion d'azf des
inscrits au chômage ils sont traités
comme tout le monde
soumis à des carences ils n'ont pas
touché un sou depuis trois mois à lui
faire attention au final on a vécu sur
les 5000 femmes de ma femme on se
retrouve dans le droit commun des
personnes qui ont perdu leur emploi
face à cela du fait de cette catastrophe
on aurait pu là aussi attendre des
mesures exceptionnelles que ces
personnes n'est pas le moindre mois sans
revenus et non jacquerie vi a gardé ses
salariés mais au prix de quels
sacrifices
moi ce qui me fait mal c'est que les
salariés m'ont dit à la noël
nos enfants ils n'ont pas eu le conte de
noël qu'on n'a pas les finances c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas fini mais je
suppose que le directeur de total elles
finale du acteurs ou les oeufs
ils ont eu un noël d'antan aux yeux noël
mais ça personne ne va le payer sa part
5 6 ans le garage fonctionne encore au
ralenti
les mécaniciens ne se plaignent pas
pourtant eux aussi pelli suite de la
catastrophe
les assises du gers ont condamné hier
soir kamel ben salah la peine maximum
perpétuité assortie d'une période de
sûreté de 22 ans pour les meurtres de
quatre touristes néerlandais dans leur
maison de montfort bensalah qui proteste
de son innocence et va faire appel de ce
jugement
a nantes la nuit dernière un homme qui
était placé en garde à vue pour
tentative de meurtre a réussi à s'évader
de la gendarmerie
il est fait pourtant menotté un anneau
scellé dans le mur
on ignore comment il a réussi à se faire
la belle quelques jours après la
tentative d'un 110 de la synagogue de
montpellier trois hommes vont être
écroué après être passé aux aveux
apparemment il s'agirait d'un acte isolé
veronica guillaume et françois mazou il
ya moins de 48 heures il buvait des
bières entre copains sans même imaginer
c'est ce qu'ils affirment qu'il
s'attaquerait tu as une synagogue et les
voix la mise en examen pour dégradations
volontaires de biens par incendie
pas un acte de terrorisme donc plutôt de
délinquance je pense que ce sont trois
individus dont je vous dis que deux
étaient bien connus et des services de
la police et aussi de la justice qui
dans une nuit où ils ont sans doute un
peu trop consommé ont voulu lui donner
ce qu'il pensait être un sens à leur
désoeuvrement
ils ont grandi tous les trois dans de
petites communes de l'arrière pays ce
sont des jeunes de l'immigration mais
pas des islamistes pas même des
pratiquants ici l'un d'eux était plutôt
connu pour des faits de violences et de
vol f que c'était quelqu'un qui a été
repérée comme antisémites faisant des
actes par la connaissance par ma
connaissance
alors bien sûr il avait bu il ne savait
pas trop comment finir leur soirée ils
ont parlé des évènements en territoire
palestinien
et puis ils ont voulu faire quelque
chose aussi alors ils ont préparé des
cocktails molotov qu'ils se sont trompés
de fenêtres mais c'est bien à la
synagogue qui l'on voulait les petits
délinquants ont je pense
imaginez qu'ils allaient devenir des
héros et des rambo si leurs actes de
délinquance allait s'orienter sur des
synagogues contre des lieux juifs contre
des intérêts juifs le fait qu'il soit
resté sur les lieux après leurs gestes
c'est penser que rien n'était vraiment
préparés ou commanditer les trois jeunes
mis en examen encourent dix ans
d'emprisonnement
avant ces manifestations prévues
dimanche prochain pour dénoncer les
actes antisémites sont déroulé
aujourd'hui une réunion d'urgence au
pré-saint-gervais en seine-saint-denis
la préoccupation et l'inquiétude de ces
familles qui craignent une montée de la
violence
yann frantic david foster 10h22 j'étais
à tulle
donc je voulais juste il y à 21 et sage
depuis le début de la semaine certains
apple après s'être fait insulter ou
agressé d'autres pour confié leur
angoisse c'est un simple téléphone
répondeur à l'arrière de la synagogue
qui fait office de numéro d'urgence ça
nous permet de recenser tous les actes
qui sont commis au quotidien contre tout
un chacun enfin tout un chacun aux juifs
qui subit un acte une agression anti
juives dans la salle des fêtes réunion
de crise les représentants de la
communauté juive on avait déjà tenu de
semblable il y a deux ans lors de la
seconde intifada
autour de la table des sensibilités
diverses mais un seul constat la
situation n'a jamais été aussi alarmant
agressé à la courneuve avec les enfants
plusieurs fois l'inquiétude est devenue
quotidienne presque permanente
le rabais de la communauté m'a dit il ne
faut plus mettre la kippa dans la rue ne
pas pouvoir porter une kippa
c'est déjà un signe grave dans une
démocratie comme celle de la france
dimanche ils diront tous manifesté à
paris avec un seul mot d'ordre en être
dénoncés une fois pour toutes la
multiplication des agressions
antisémites en france la situation au
proche orient autour de la basilique de
la nativité à bethléem où sont toujours
retranchés 200 à 300 palestiniens
plusieurs explosions ont été entendues
ce matin dans cette ville où des
ressortissants français et italiens
notamment entré volontairement la
semaine dernière comme boucliers humains
ont demandé à être évacués aujourd'hui
comme le monde ce reportage d'alain
salvan et de gilles jacquier il y à la
18 voitures des consulats de france
d'italie d'allemagne des pays bas et de
suisse
le soft au checkpoint de pedja là à
l'entrée de bethléem
il s'agit de sortir 58 ressortissants
européens bloqués dans un camp
palestinien
tout a été négocié avec les israéliens
dernières consignes ce que je propose et
c'est que vous ne sentez pas des
véhicules ou alors si vous sortiez
minutes en sécurité feu vert nous
entrant avec les airs de chars par
l'entrée du camp nouvelles négociations
par téléphone cette fois ci les blindés
finalement
voilà voix
l'atmosphère est particulièrement lourd
10 les européens sont regroupés dans un
immeuble en lisière du camp prêt à
partir
ils sont tous venus volontairement la
semaine dernière pour servir de
boucliers humains
mais la plupart craque les adieux sont
parfois déchirants on souhaitait très
grande table il était d'enrayer une
mécanique infernale
je ne suis pas content de les voir
partir parce que pour notre peuple c'est
plus sûr quand ils sont là en train de
la demande pourquoi bord à 13 heures un
peu poussé par les gendarmes français
tout le monde embarque la consule
adjointe et soulagé bien on sort nos
jambes un peu vite alors que madame
roussel nous explique qu'il va falloir
s'arrêter dans un autre camp chercher
deux autres personnes
les gendarmes déploient immédiatement
leurs balises de protection en kevlar
pour mettre la représentante française à
l'abri dans un 4 4 lundi
pendant ce temps la fusillade ce no
apparemment les tirs de mitrailleuses de
blindés israéliens en ricochet des tirs
d'intimidation
il n'y a pas eu de blessés mais on a
entendu les balles siffler ou plan
diplomatique l'amérique qui sort de son
silence après les déclarations hier de
george bush son émissaire anthony zinni
a pu rencontrer yasser arafat à ramallah
pour autant les opérations militaires
israéliennes se poursuivent l'action
d'ariel sharon largement soutenu par la
population selon des sondages publiés
aujourd'hui
charles enderlin anthony zinni
l'émissaire américain est en route pour
le qg d'arafat à ramallah
quelques journalistes tentent de couvrir
l'événement mais l'armée israëlienne
veille la route est barrée par un char
et les confrères sont repoussés à l'aide
de grenades un cameramen n'a pas de
problème
il peut filmer l'arrivée de zine
ishihara pattes il est en uniforme c'est
le caméraman de tsahal l'armée
israélienne qui a commencé à déployer
ses propres équipes là où la presse
étrangère est interdite heures monsieur
unis est reparti une heure plus tard
escorté par la sécurité américaine
les agences de presse ont obtenu ces
photos les seules images de la rencontre
l'armée nous a également fourni
gracieusement cette vidéo d'un
laboratoire d'explosifs qu'il a
découvert à naplouse et où étaient
fabriquées les ceintures des kamikazes
et voici toujours filmé par un militaire
l'évacuation de prêtres catholiques d'un
couvent proche de la basilique de la
nativité
il refuse d'accorder des interviews
selon le dernier sondage 72% des
israéliens soutiennent la politique
d'ariel sharon
l'opération dans les territoires
palestiniens et cela sur tous ses
aspects y compris les limites imposées à
la presse étrangère
les officiels affirmant que certains
reportages porte atteinte à l'image de
marque d'israël voyons à présent la
situation dans les pays arabes
plusieurs manifestations de soutien au
peuple palestinien
ce sont des roule avec une certaine
violence comme amman en jordanie où des
milliers de manifestants marquer leur
colère à l'égard d'israël et des états
unis
les incidents ont opposé forces de
l'ordre à la foule qui voulait se rendre
à l'ambassade américaine la police anti
émeutes est entrée en action par
ailleurs en turquie la police a utilisé
des lances à eau et des gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser quelques 3000 personnes
rassemblées à istanbul après la prière
du vendredi
enfin l'iran propose aux pays islamistes
de producteurs de pétrole de suspendre
pendant un mois
de façon symbolique l'approvisionnement
des pays occidentaux pour faire pression
sur les pays qui soutiennent israël
en france la campagne présidentielle à
lyon la tournante d'un jour pour les
candidats d'abord hier soir le premier
discours du juge halphen en vedette
américaine du meeting de jean pierre
chevènement reportage
arnaud bouter olivier robert entrée en
politique ce n'est pas toujours évident
alors vous êtes toujours vivant l'ancien
magistrat et mais la discrétion le
politique répond à toutes les questions
et pour justifier son engagement eric
halphen lui aussi évoque le désir aussi
ses désirs alors ses désirs pour
beaucoup de candidats non mais moi c'est
désir d'aider les gens de jean pierre
chevènement il vante l'honnêteté et le
courage et pour le candidat à ce soutien
réveil un souvenir en l'écoutant eric
halphen
j'ai le sentiment de rajeunir est de
retrouver je dirais la fraîcheur de mon
premier engagement
premier meeting premier discours devant
1500 personnes eric halphen va plaider
pour une grande réforme de la justice et
une modification du financement des
partis politiques
pour l'ancien juge il y a urgence les
chefs d'entreprise lorsqu'ils en vienne
aux confidences
une fois le procès verbal d'audition
terminée ne s'en cache pas la corruption
continue comme avant et touche tous les
grands partis politiques
qu'il s'agisse des partis de droite ou
des partis de gauche
après la présidentielle les législatives
eric halphen devrait être candidat dans
quelle circonscription mystère à lyon
l'ancien magistrat aura parlé de ses
convictions sans évoquer son ambition
quant à françois bayrou et robert hue
chacun s'était entouré de forts soutiens
pour marquer leur discours lyonnais le
candidat à la présidentielle de l'udf
qui plus que jamais se dit sûr de sa
remontée alix bouilhaguet hellénique
françois bayrou en est convaincu si
aujourd'hui les sondages frémissants sa
faveur
c'est un style qui commence à payer
c'est pas les grandes machines c'est pas
des discours avec des prompteurs et des
publicitaires les crimes
moi je m'impose comme discipline de
toujours improvisé
hier soir dans une brasserie de lyon il
est passé aux travaux pratiques
1h30 d'improvisation face à lui un
millier de personnes et en guest star
raymond barre si l'ancien premier
ministre ne cache pas son soutien à
françois bâillon au premier tour il
n'oublie pas pour autant le second mon
choix du premier tour ne signifie en
aucun cas une opposition à jacques
chirac
à quelques rues de là une autre
brasserie un autre style un autre
candidat bloqués dans les sondages
autour de 6%
robert lui non plus n'est pas venu seul
jean claude gayssot l'accompagnent
direction villeurbanne et son gymnase
devant 2000 personnes le candidat
communiste met les points sur les i
faire une mise au point
mon adversaire c'est la droite c'est
quelqu'un qui s'appelle ernest antoine
chirac et c'est certainement pas arlette
laguiller que ça soit clair les deux
candidats n'ont aujourd'hui qu'une seule
obsession la barre des 5% la dépasser
pour françois bayrou rester au dessus
pour robert hue lionel jospin était
aujourd'hui en allemagne une rencontre
prévue avec le chancelier gerhard
schröder l'occasion également pour le
premier ministre candidat d'aller au
devant des français installés à berlin
enel jospin qui devrait faire un
discours sur l'europe et les relations
franco allemandes dans la cathédrale
française vous savez désormais il ya six
candidats officiels pour la course à
l'elysée selon le dernier baromètre de
la sofres celle-ci politique opinion
publiée aujourd'hui jacques chirac
l'emporterait au deuxième tour avec 51%
des suffrages soit 2% de plus
d'intentions de vote
quant à lionel jospin il obtiendrait 49%
soit -2%
les associations d'handicapés décidés à
interpeller les deux principaux
candidats pour leur demander des
engagements publics
elles ont déposé au qg des candidats
chirac et jospin
les sacs de lettres contenant
témoignages de soutien et deux cent
mille signatures
une pétition collectés dans toute la
france 18 associations se retrouveront
d'ailleurs demain sur l'esplanade des
invalides pour qu'enfin ils réussissent
à se faire entendre
ceci nous amène à ses carnets de
campagne rendez vous quotidien de nos
journaux cette fois ci précisément ce
sont des personnes handicapées qui
donnent leur avis de citoyen christophe
duchiron prévenant les cieux avant de
donner sa voix il faut se faire entendre
malgré les regards fuyants et les
passants pressés
bonjour militants de base se lavait ou
qu'on vit à montreuil avec une cause à
défendre et un message à faire passer
je regrette et nous regrettons mais ce
que je peux parler de personnes
handicapées au parc faunique
on ne prononce pas une seule fois le mot
handicapés sur les plateaux de
télévision dans la presse
c'est un manque de courage
aujourd'hui 5 millions de personnes
handicapées en france attend des hommes
politiques
autre chose que des slogans la france
ensemble une france plus juste et cetera
et cetera des immeubles hlm au d'horreur
du cercle républicain paris où cela
venco et ses amis se réunissent de temps
à autre pour faire le point un sujet
tabou il ya une question taboue on pense
que l'électorat où les hommes politiques
pensent que l'électorat des personnes
handicapées parents présentent peu de
choses ils sont tous d'accord qu'il faut
faire quelque chose pour les personnes
handicapées une question pourquoi ne le
font-ils pas nous avons l'impression de
vivre au moyen âge parce que naît la
france est tout à fait en retard pour
l'accessibilité des transports en commun
le collectif des démocrates handicapés
présentait un candidat qui voulait
donner la parole à ceux qui ne l'ont
jamais les fautes de recueillir les 500
signatures il n'y a plus de candidats et
une fois encore les handicapés devront
compter sur les autres les hommes
politiques
je pense que le changeur de regards il
accepter davantage la paire
disparaissent
ça viendra je suis confiant à l'occasion
des présidentielles l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure à nîmes sans doute chaque
citoyen maintenant réduit un quasi
silence un handicapé et qui l'a citoyens
comme les autres
c'est ce candidat donc validée par le
conseil constitutionnel un nombre record
qui pose dans certaines communes le
problème de l'implantation de panneaux
électoraux jugé trop coûteux par les
petits villages entre débrouille et
système d album écho si val suzon en
bourgogne 194 habitants et comme partout
16 candidats à la présidentielle ça fait
beaucoup
17 panneaux sampaio 0 stade et ce
panneau ce sont deux candidats au
passage élu maire l'an dernier catherine
louis doit improviser
la commune ne possède que neuf panneaux
en métal galvanisé chaque nouvel
exemplaire coûte 250 euros pièce alors
madame le maire a pris des mesures les
candidats devront se serrer bon
l'installer ce matin même nos panneaux
qui sont en bien sûr réglementaire et
mais nos panneaux devront être divisé
par deux pour pouvoir accueillir toutes
les affiches faut pas gâcher comme on
dit aussi dans le limousin à saint
brisson a ressorti les bons vieux
panneaux en bois des années 60
aujourd'hui les 36000 maires de france
ont reçu la liste officielle des
candidats et l'ordre attribué à chacun
par tirage au sort
en 95 entre les bulletins les affiches
officielles les deux tours de la
présidentielle avait coûté 880 millions
de francs de l'époque à l'état sans
parler de l'installation de panneaux
dans les communes alors à chacun sa
solution à puisant valent en normandie
pour éviter le gaspillage on fait les
panneaux sur place bon à moindre frais
puisqu'on va le faire nous mêmes nos
corps se met à la peinture pour que ce
soit fait puis en val 25 électeurs 16
candidats cette campagne électorale à la
campagne prête parfois à sourire et puis
on a appris que loïk le floch prigent
l'ex pdg d'elf spitz alizés à beyrouth
est arrivé ce soir à paris il devrait
comparaître en mai prochain dans le
dossier health
la réforme universitaire annoncée par le
ministre de l'éducation aujourd'hui de
véritables changements qui prendront
leur place progressivement avec
notamment l'harmonisation européenne des
diplômes jack lang qui souhaitent créer
des diplômes à crédit ou encore le
transfert d'une université à l'autre
d'un pays à l'autre nicolas et marie née
la passion de cosmin à ce sont les
langues étrangères en roumanie elle
prépare une maîtrise de traduction à
rennes elle suit des cours de langues
étrangères appliquées
mais les matières ne sont pas les mêmes
alors pour valider cette parenthèse
française dans son pays d'origine
il y a le système décrit dans chaque
matière vote un certain nombre de
crédits valable dans toute l'europe
indique cette technique c'est un rôle
important
4 que dis je pense traduction
commerciale encore il ne reste qu'à
composer le menu pour valider une année
ben au total il me faut 30
et oui je le suis un rassembler
assez de copeaux fac 30 clips le système
qui existe déjà à rennes va se
généraliser à la rentrée une licence
représentera par exemple 180 crédits en
france comme en roumanie
ce seront les premiers pas d'un cursus
universitaire européen pour l'instant le
titre par exemple de licences peut être
dispensé en france au bout de trois
années de formation dans certains pays
de l'est ce bout de quatre années
donc il n'ya pas de le titre même ne
signifie pas un temps d'études
équivalent un nouveau diplôme va
également faire son apparition le master
un bac + 5 qui voudra 300 crédit qui
sera le même dans toutes les universités
d'europe
quand l'administration est trop prudente
depuis deux ans les autorités sanitaires
françaises bloquent l'autorisation d'un
nouveau procédé de lutte contre la
légionellose la maladie fait pourtant
plus de 100 morts chaque année et des
centaines de malades
romuald venant eric ni si la légionelle
cette bactérie redoutable se cachent
dans les réseaux d'eau chaude les
climatisations les fontaines publiques
en france l'an passé elle a rendu
malades 600 personnes 110 n'ont pas
survécu
pour la combattre pierre-olivier jose
dispose d'une nouvelle arme
nom de code ionisation cuivre argent en
clair un courant électrique permet de
dissoudre d'infimes particules de cuivre
d'argent dans les canalisations des
particules mortel pour les bactéries un
système simple et peu coûteux utilisé
ici à monaco mais aussi partout en
europe et en amérique du nord
seulement voilà l'administration
française elle refuse de l'autoriser
s'aperçoit tu cette rame seul pays au
monde qui n'a pas eu cette technologie
quelque part je me dis que là quelque
chose qui va pas
motif des autorités sanitaires ce
procédé n'est pas conforme à une
réglementation qui impose une certaine
teneur en argent dans l'eau une limite
que la loi européenne ne mentionne même
pas face aux risques pour la santé en
france des entreprises des hôpitaux des
municipalités préfère se mettre hors la
loi c'est le cas ici à rueil malmaison
il ya un an c'est complexe sportif a été
équipée du système
après une épidémie de légionellose mais
si l'on est immédiat avec les pistes
d'un traitement par chlore qui au bout
de huit jours ne nous donnait pas
satisfaction nous avons donc installé
cet appareil qui permet ligne
l'ionisation de l'eau et qu'ils nous
donnent entière satisfaction
autre souci cet appareil n'est pas
autorisée en france si l'administration
persiste et signe
de leur côté les familles des victimes
mettent en garde les autorités
sanitaires tous les morts qui vont
arriver
faute d'avoir utilisé ce procédé
pourrait demain sur aux conditions
retourner contre eux pendant ce temps
les contaminations se multiplient il ya
quinze jours trois personnes sont mortes
à nice accusé l'eau des fontaines le
grand jour de ma pour le quinze de
france la dernière marche vers le grand
chelem si les tricolores l'emportent sur
l'irlande
le match sera retransmis en direct bien
sûr sur france 2 à moins de 24 heures de
la rencontre
coup de projecteur sur bernard laporte
l'entraîneur du quinze de france décrit
au départ et désormais encensé par les
joueurs christophe duchiron frédéric
bazille finalement c'était une semaine
comme les autres c'était la farandole du
verbe et du rugby
le pourquoi du comment le discours de la
méthode armé d'un organe vocal de
compétition chez bernard laporte la
parole est d'or le silence d'argent et
les coups de gueule aussi fréquents que
la pluie en bretagne ont marqué tout de
suite mais ils ont bien pour attaquer
les nez c'est tout c'est au lycée faire
des compliments
il sait faire des analyses pour ce qui
est la gestuelle avec bernard laporte on
est sans conteste dans le registre de la
comédie à la française plus proche
d'aubry de funès que vous ouvert
des fois il s'emporte un petit peu mais
c'est moi je connais je connais peu de
personnes encore de cette qualité là
volonté de coller aux prises atteindre
chf le chercheur islandais
ancien joueur de rugby si un champion de
france avec bègles bordeaux est tout
jeune entraîneur 38 ans seulement
laporte vit désormais les matchs par
procuration en un curieux mélange de
frustration de douleurs parfois et de
joie fugitif
c'est un peu comme les grands metteurs
en scène quand ils sont pas contents de
leur de leurs de la production de leurs
acteurs il soigne les idées et s'oriente
soit idée d subissent bernard laporte
est quand même bien davantage qu'un
entraîneur qui donnent de la voix
il est perfectionniste et ambitieux
après deux dernières saisons difficiles
le quinze de france reste depuis le mois
de juin sur sept victoires consécutives
un huitième succès demain face à
l'irlande et ce sera le grand chelem
alors avec les bleus bernard laporte
pourra crier tout son bonheur
ainsi se termine ce journal je remercie
de votre attention tout de suite
élections 2002 face à la rédaction qui
reçoit bruno mégret ce soir demain 7h
dans thé ou café catherine ceylac
recevra la chanteuse jouera quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de nous retrouver
demain dès 13h excellente soirée sur
france 2 il nous quitte on sur ces
images de l'ouverture plus 18e salon de
la musique musicorama
on
oh
non
comme ça